but roughly speaking ever since Margaret
Thatcher for every two pounds we pay in
we get one pound back and that one pound
we get back is under conditions so I
think we're gonna be stronger because
our economy is strong if we vote leave I
think gonna be safer because we've got
greater control of our borders who vote
leave and I think you were going to be
better off and we're going to be better
off because the European Union was
created in a time when big trading
bloc's existed they don't exist anymore
what we've got now is global trading of
goods global trading of services and we
also have global movement of people none
of these things the EO is capable of
dealing with it has outgrown its time I
wish the euro countries well they need
deeper integration they need it because
I don't want whole generations of young
people to be on the heap of unemployment
I wish them well I think we're better
off to vote leave if we are strong and
they're strong than the continent of
Europe is strong if we collectively weak
that will serve no one so take control
vote leave thank you